Kingsman the Secret Service is directed
by Matthew Vaughn and stars Colin Firth
samuel l.jackson mark Strong Taran
Edgerton I believe is how you say his
name and it's a total love letter to
old-school British spy films what this
film is about is a group called the
Kingsmen these guys are the ultimate
badasses of the universe but they're
also very gentlemanly people who are
extremely good at killing people with
just about anything available to them
and when Colin Firth's character gets
the opportunity to recruit this very
young kid who is actually the son of her
former Kingsman he grabs a whole that
opportunity trains him and teaches him
how to not only be an ultimate badass
but a gentleman Matthew Vaughn's been a
director I've admired for quite some
time I think the guy's really talented
if you haven't seen a layer cake it's
one of his earlier films and very
overlooked and some people actually
consider it might be the film that got
Daniel Craig the Bond role and Matthew
Vaughn's love of spy films is very
apparent with this movie and he is very
good at crafting action scenes this is
something that I've talked about
recently action scenes action heroes the
way they're choreographed the way
they're filmed Kingsman does a fantastic
job at presenting a very stylish and
modern look at the way action is but you
can also tell what's going on the stunts
are great and it also tributes the very
old-school style of like villains with
crazy dismemberments or weird parts
about their body a lot of Bond villains
are like that and in this film a very
very awesome girl has blades for feet
and she is great in this movie very
intimidating also the character of Roxy
who is a girl who is also training to
try to be the next Kingsman she was
awesome as well and samuel l.jackson as
the villain knocked it out of the park
at first I was like I don't know about
this Lisp it was a little waterboy esque
was like that's like my h2o I'm gonna
open up a cannibal bath on you but in
the long run it actually worked and then
added a lot to the movie and it made him
a more interesting character Colin Firth
also was fantastic in the action scenes
and this was something I was very
curious about Colin Firth action hero I
don't know about that but he did a great
job and I read on the IMDB trivia that
he apparently did most of his own stunts
around 80% of them which is great and
something I also have been complain
about in action films recently now I
really want to talk about who is
essentially the main character of the
movie Taron Egerton if I said his name
incorrectly I apologize he was fantastic
in this movie his stunt work was awesome
he gave a lot of humanity to his
performance and that is also something I
really want to touch on every character
in this movie the major ones anyway has
something about him or her that makes
them a human being has a great past a
really great set up so you can actually
care about them when the action starts
this is another problem I've been having
with action movies lately and this movie
solved that when the movie opened with
dire straits money for nothing I was
like okay this soundtrack is gonna be
great
dire straits is one of my favorite bands
from the 80s Mark Knopfler was a lead
singer and he's one of my favorite
guitarists if not my favorite guitarist
and not a lot of people ever really talk
about him or have his music and movies
so it was really cool to see that just a
side note on dire straits check out the
guitar solo Sultans of Swing alchemy
live best guitar solo these ears have
ever heard another film that very
recently tried to tribute classic spy
films was Mordecai and it did it
entirely wrong this film shows you how
to do it entirely right the action is
extremely fun it's well filmed it's well
performed the characters have something
about them that makes them human they're
interesting they're funny and there are
moments in the film that are a little
boundary-pushing I mean there's a part
where my jaw dropped and I said Colin
Firth is killing people in a church this
is nuts
it worked though and I wouldn't really
describe this movie as predictable
either and that's something I really
liked about it as well it was kind of
hard to see where certain things were
going my small issues with the film is
that there are some character arcs that
seem like they're not really completed
when the film ends no I didn't get up
right when the credits start because
about a minute into the credits there is
an after credits scene that finishes off
a confrontation and I was very happy
about that but there are other character
confrontations that I was expecting to
come up a little bit more at some point
and there are times when the film is a
little bit uneven in its pacing besides
that I had an immense time with Kingsman
Secret Service I would highly recommend
seeing it and I'm gonna give it an A -
Oh finally experiencing a drought lately
so good to see a good movie in theaters
guys what are your thoughts on Kingsman
if you have seen it and if you haven't
please do be
there were like four people in my
theater please go see this movie it's
good give it a little bit of dope guys
sincerely thank you very much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck Minh
iced